I tried to avoid doing this ever since
the picture came out because when you
just say the ideas they sound uh foolish
whereas if they're dramatized or one
feels it but I'll try the idea was
supposed to be that he is taken in by
god-like entities creatures of pure
energy and intelligence with no shape or
form they put him uh in what I suppose
you could describe as a human Zoo to
study him and he spends his whole life
passes from that point on in that room
and he has no sense of time they choose
this room which is a very inaccurate
replica of uh French architecture
deliberately so inaccurate because you
know one was suggesting that they
weren't quite sure just as we aren't
quite sure and what to do and Zeus try
to give them what we think is their
natural you know environment anyway when
they get finished with him he is
transformed into some kind of super
being and sent back to Earth uh and we
not we have to only guess what happens
when he goes back